irán viene desde hace días señalando de
ilegal la intención de estados unidos de
activar este snap back o este mecanismo
por el cual uno de los países firmantes
del acuerdo nuclear con irán en el 2015
tiene el poder de reactivar las
sanciones en el contexto de la de este
organismo de las naciones unidas e irán
no cumple esto lo firmado durante el
acuerdo irán ha dicho que esto es
absolutamente ilegal y es que recordemos
que fue estados unidos el que se retiró
del acuerdo en 2018 y en teoría bajo lo
firmado no tiene ningún derecho de
reactivar o de activar este mecanismo en
el consejo de seguridad de las naciones
unidas como se lo ha recordado el
ministro de exteriores mohamad yavad
sharif al secretario de las naciones
unidas en el que ha dicho que no
solamente eeuu se sentirá aislado y
caerán desgracia el contexto
internacional sino que esto también
puede deteriorar la credibilidad del
consejo de seguridad de las naciones
unidas si esto se lleva realmente esto
se pone y se discute
institución recordemos que países que
tienen puestos allí como rusia china
francia e inglaterra
sumado a alemania han rechazado ya esta
posición de los eeuu